.
Das war nicht so geplant,
v.a. nicht
auf der anderen Seite der Welt.
Dass er Marokkaner
und nicht Schweizer ist -
das ist klar, das ist etwas,
was mir sehr attraktiv scheint.
"Nein,
ich will keinen Athleten daten."
"Keinen, der so gross und dunkel,
so schwarz ist."
* Romantische Musik *
# Take my hand, take me anywhere,
as long as you are there.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be
forever you and me.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Herzschläge *
(Etwas wissen wir inzwischen:
Liebe kennt keine Grenzen.)
(Und sie fragt auch nicht
nach dem Pass.)
* Verspielte Klänge *
(Liebe kann weit entfernte Menschen
miteinander verbinden.)
(Aber sie kann auch
Menschen voneinander trennen,
die eigentlich
von Geburt an zusammengehören.)
(Das ist "Hin und weg".)
Sie sehen wirklich gleich aus.
Mona.
- Hallo, Mona.
(Vor noch nicht langer Zeit
wurde Martinas Leben plötzlich
buchstäblich auf den Kopf gestellt.)
Hättest du gedacht,
den Mann deines Leben ausgerechnet
in Australien zu treffen?
Definitiv nicht. Gar nicht.
Ich habe überhaupt nicht
damit gerechnet.
Als wir nach Australien reisten,
gab es einige Leute, die sagten:
"Pass auf, die Australier
sind liebe und nette Leute."
Ist das bekannt?
Ich habe das ein paar Mal gehört,
als ich von der Reise erzählte.
Und wie es sein muss: Man geht
abends aus und dann kommt der Eine.
Wie ist es geschehen?
Wir sind ganz spontan ausgegangen.
Es war gar nicht geplant.
Wir haben zwei andere
Schweizerinnen getroffen.
Wir waren mit
unserer besten Freundin unterwegs.
Wir waren also
fünf Schweizerinnen in Noosa.
Wir gingen in den Club rein
und ich sah ihn dort stehen.
Ich sagte zu Melanie:
"Schau mal, der dort drüben
gefällt mir ganz gut."
Sie fand auch: "Der ist schön."
Ich merkte,
dass er Augenkontakt herstellte.
Irgendwann sagte Melanie:
"Jetzt geh endlich zu ihm hin."
Ich habe es in die Wege geleitet.
So kamen Cahil und ich ins Gespräch
und lernten uns kennen.
Also, eigentlich ist Melanie schuld.
Konnte er euch beide
auseinanderhalten
oder gab es Momente,
in denen er euch verwechselte?
Ja, am zweiten Abend,
als wir uns trafen.
Wir sassen in einem Cafe,
wo wir mit Cahil verabredet waren.
Er kam an den Tisch
und setzte sich neben Melanie.
Das war echt lustig.
Ich dachte nur: "Oh, oh, weiss er,
dass ich nicht Melanie bin?"
Ich sagte dann:
"Weisst du, dass sie Martina ist?"
Er sprang auf
und wollte es nicht glauben.
Hier ist er - der Grund.
Wir haben viel von dir gehört.
Natürlich nur Gutes.
Only good things.
Du bist also der Grund,
warum Martina
ihre Schwester, ihre Familie
und die Schweiz verlassen will.
Unglücklicherweise ja.
Wusstest du immer schon,
dass die Frau deines Lebens
eine Ausländerin sein wird?
Nein, wirklich nicht.
Überhaupt nicht.
Nicht von der anderen Seite
der Welt.
Mich hat das Reisen
nie gross interessiert,
bevor ich Martina traf.
Ich ging immer davon aus,
dass ich meine Zeit
in meiner Schreinerei verbringen,
meine Aufträge erledigen
und Militärdienst leisten würde.
Und dann die Freizeit
mit meinem Hund, meinen Leuten
und meinem Auto geniessen würde.
Und jetzt ist es natürlich hart,
dass ich Martina allen wegnehme.
Aber eben ...
Vor euch liegt
ein ganz grosser Schritt. - Ja.
Ich verspüre sehr viel Vorfreude.
Aber ich verspüre
fast gleich viel Traurigkeit.
Nicht nur wegen ihr, sondern auch
wegen unseren Eltern und Freunden.
Auch die Schweiz.
Ich werde die Schweiz vermissen.
(Wir begleiten Martina und Cahil
bei diesem grossen Schritt.)
(Aber zuerst treffen wir an der
Ostküste Afrikas ein zweites Paar,
das aus
unterschiedlichen Kulturen stammt.)
(In diesem interessanten Haus
direkt am Strand
wohnt Nicole seit zwei Jahren.)
(Vielleicht
kommt sie Ihnen bekannt vor.)
(Nicole Pavlin
hat vor über zehn Jahren
beim Schweizer Fernsehen
verschiedene Sendungen moderiert.)
(Dann hat sie ihre Koffer gepackt
und ist in die Welt hinausgezogen.)
* Meeresrauschen *
Ja, das ist ...
Das tut gut.
Das tut wirklich gut.
Manchmal hüpfe ich rein -
wenn ich Zeit habe.
(Als Chefin eines eigenen Hotels
und Mutter der 7-jährigen Lila
ist Zeit aber ein seltenes Gut.)
Lila?
Guten Morgen.
Jalla.
Voila, komm.
Okay?
Komm.
Gehst du schon mal vor?
Papa kommt.
Geh schon mal ins Restaurant.
- I don't wanna go.
Wartest du auf Papa?
Okay.
Morning.
- (Frau) Morning.
(Jeden Morgen kommen die Angestellten
bei Nicole vorbei,
um die Informationen
zu den neuen Gästen abzuholen.)
Wir haben vier Neuankünfte.
Dann eine Abreise.
Für Lala
haben wir keine neuen Gäste.
Und vergiss die Honeymoon-Suite
nicht.
Easy.
(Seit elf Jahren ist Rachid
der Mann an Nicoles Seite.)
(Als sie sich kennenlernten,
war er Polizeiinspektor in
der marokkanischen Stadt Essaouira.)
Tschüss.
Bye, bye, Mama.
Bye, bye.
- Bye.
* Herzschlag *
Es war nicht Liebe auf den
ersten Blick, sondern einfach ...
"Das ist dein Mann."
Oder: "Ich bin seine Frau."
Aber es war einfach
eine Klarheit da.
Und die Liebe kam erst danach,
mit dem Kennenlernen.
Wir waren nicht mehr die Jüngsten.
Wir hatten auch keinen Rucksack.
Wir waren nicht verheiratet,
hatten damals keine Kinder.
Mit 40 ist das ziemlich selten.
(Während der ersten acht Jahre
lebten Rachid und Nicole
in seiner Heimat Marokko.)
(Vor drei Jahren nahmen sie dieses
Projekt in Sansibar in Angriff.)
(Sie als Chefin und Bauherrin,
er unterstützt sie
und hält ihr den Rücken frei.)
(Fast jeden Tag bringt er Lila
und eine Freundin zur Schule.)
* Entspannte Klänge *
C'est pas grave.
C'est a qui, ca?
- C'est a moi.
(20 km hin und wieder 20 km zurück.)
(Und zum Abholen nochmals.)
Sansibar war nicht meine Idee.
Ich habe das nicht gewählt.
Der Deal war,
dass ich meinen Job als
Kriminalpolizist an den Nagel hänge
und etwas Neues mitaufbaue.
Ich hatte eher
an etwas in Marokko gedacht.
Ich hätte es vorgezogen, wenn Lila
in Marokko aufgewachsen wäre -
oder in der Schweiz.
Jedenfalls in der Nähe. Mit mehr
Zivilisation als hier in Afrika.
Sie muss ja was lernen.
Jalla, Lila.
Your bag?
(Lila besucht eine internationale
Schule für Kinder von Expats.)
Let Papa put the bag in place.
And after the line-up ...
I like these shoes.
* Die Kinder singen ein Lied. *
(Hierhin also hat es
die Schweizerin Nicole Pavlin
und den Marokkaner
Rachid Hirach-Idrissi verschlagen:
auf Sansibar,
die Insel mit dem klingenden Namen,
die zu Tansania gehört.)
(Gestern Abend
habe ich sie nur kurz begrüsst.)
(Erst jetzt
nehme ich so richtig wahr,
in was für einem Paradies
ich hier gelandet bin.)
Ich komme einfach frech herein.
- Ja, hallo.
Hey.
- Bist du im Büro?
Erledigst du Büroarbeiten?
- Im Büro. Hallo, komm bitte.
Ich bin noch gar nie ...
Das ist euer Privathaus? - Ja.
Da bin ich noch gar nie gewesen.
Ich habe erst das Hotel ...
- Es ist nicht für jeden zugänglich.
Obwohl wir
direkt neben den Gästen sind.
Es hat alles hier angefangen,
mit diesem Haus?
Ja, es stand schon.
Es war illegal gebaut worden.
Ganz nah am Meer.
Man muss einen Abstand einhalten.
- Von wem wurde es gebaut?
Vom vorherigen Besitzer.
Deshalb musste er es
ganz schnell verkaufen.
Und zurück, nach Hause.
Wir brachten es dann in Ordnung
mit den Papieren.
Als wir hier ankamen,
war es noch nicht fertig gebaut.
Es war so eine Sache
mit dem Vorbesitzer.
Der Anfang war schwierig
mit dem Typen aus Kenia.
Als wir dann mit dem Umbau begannen,
schliefen wir alle zusammen
in diesem Raum nebenan.
Darf ich es anschauen?
- Klar.
Darf ich so frech sein?
- Wo zuerst?
Gut, das ist ...
(Französisch) Ist das die Küche?
Ja,
normalerweise wäre das die Küche.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Jahr Arbeit.
So eine Küche
würde man sich wünschen.
D.h., du musst nie selber kochen.
- Richtig.
Genau.
Ich koche gerne -
wenn ich Zeit habe - für Freunde.
Aber das alltägliche Kochen
ist für mich Horror.
Esst ihr im Restaurant?
Ja, wir können
immer im Restaurant essen.
Manchmal brauchen wir etwas Distanz.
Dann können wir aber bestellen.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich bin zu Hause,
wenn meine Sachen da sind.
Kunst, das muss da sein.
Dann fühle ich mich auch daheim.
Er ist sich das nach zwölf Jahren
gewöhnt.
Es ist immer dabei. Auch in Marokko.
- Ja.
Das hat ein Freund gemalt.
Frauenkörper gefallen mir sowieso.
Ich finde es schön, wenn es zurück-
geht in die Natur, zu den Wurzeln.
And ...
(Französisch) Und dir, gefällt das?
Nein.
Aber es ist ihr Bild.
Mir gefällt es nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was es bedeuten soll.
Es interessiert mich
aber auch nicht.
Komm, wir gehen rauf. Ist okay.
(Eine gute Million Menschen
leben auf Sansibar.)
(Jedes Jahr kommen eine halbe Million
Touristen hierher.)
(Das Hotel, das Nicole und Rachid
vor drei Jahren gebaut haben,
bietet 22 Gästen Platz.)
* Entspannte Klänge *
Wow.
Ja.
Die Sicht ist nicht schlecht.
Wenn du auf dem Bett liegst, fühlst
du dich beinahe wie auf dem Schiff.
(Seit elf Jahren sind Nicole
und Rachid verheiratet.)
(Erst im zweiten Anlauf
hat es geklappt.)
(Der erste Versuch platzte
wegen des marokkanischen Königs.)
Ihr konntet nicht heiraten -
wegen des Königs?
Ja.
Weisst du, ein Sicherheitsmann
der Polizei darf nur ausreisen,
wenn der König im Land ist.
Also, jetzt langsam:
Ihr habt in der Schweiz geheiratet.
Genau.
Du warst in der Schweiz.
Und ihr wolltet heiraten.
Dann standest du vor dem Altar ...
Vor dem Zivilstandesamt.
Ehrlich? Und er kam nicht?
Er konnte nicht kommen.
Er versuchte, auszureisen.
Dafür brauchst du ein Papier
vom König, unterschrieben.
Das hatte er nicht,
da der König in Frankreich war.
Ich sagte ihm, er solle es
einfach versuchen am Flughafen.
Sie nahmen ihn raus, ins Büro.
Er wollte illegal ausreisen -
obwohl er nicht durfte,
da der König ausser Land war.
Sie sagten: "Wenn du nichts sagst,
haben wir dich nicht gesehen."
"Geh einfach subito nach Hause. "
Er hätte im Knast landen können.
- L'histoire du mariage. Ouais.
Ich sagte:
"Gut, wir versuchen es nochmals."
"In drei Monaten ist mein 40."
"Machen wir heute
mein Geburtstagsfest
und an meinem 40. heiraten wir."
Das ist auch der Tag
der Thronbesteigung des Königs.
Deshalb wussten wir, dass er da in
Marokko sein würde. So klappte es.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Da sieht man es.
Die Fotos sind schon etwas vergilbt.
Mit dem Salzwasser in der Luft
verfärbt sich alles.
Ah, der rosarote Filter?
- Ja.
Und dann habt ihr Ja gesagt?
-  Genau.
Nein,
wir hatten ja schon unterschrieben.
Da kannst du Ja oder Nein sagen.
Es macht keinen Unterschied mehr.
Aber sie hat uns gefragt.
Ich mache nur Spass.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Die Aussicht ist so traumhaft.
* Seufzer *
* Sie unterhalten sich leise
auf Französisch. *
* Herzschlag *
Angefangen hat es eigentlich,
als ich mal seine Facebookseite
entdeckt habe.
Also seine Reiseseite.
Dort war das Matterhorn abgebildet.
Ich fand das spannend,
denn die Seite war auf Schwedisch.
Ich habe dieses Matterhornbild
geliked.
Ich hoffe, ich erzähle dasselbe.
Ich glaube, es war - ich bin
nicht sicher - das Gipfelfoto.
Das Gipfelfoto. Dachte ich's mir.
Da war dann ein Kommentar von ihr.
So ging es hin und her.
So begann es.
* Sanfte Klänge *
(Florence und Niklas
sind verheiratet,
führen aber zurzeit
noch eine Fernbeziehung.)
(Aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Dazu kommen wir später.)
Do you wanna come with her, Leo?
(Heute müssen sie wieder
für einige Wochen Abschied nehmen.)
Wir haben mal gesagt:
"Irgendwann wird es Routine."
Aber wir haben das Gefühl, es werde
immer schlimmer und nicht Routine.
Wir sprachen gerade heute Morgen
davon.
Ja,
es sind nicht die schönen Momente.
V.a. weil wir wissen,
dass es wieder einen Monat dauert
bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja.
I said we never get used to this.
Ach, es bleibt ein Mist.
Aber so ist es nun mal.
- Ja.
Wir werden täglich miteinander
sprechen, Nachrichten schreiben
und wieder Tschüss sagen.
Aber wir haben dafür auch
sehr viele glückliche Augenblicke.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir
uns wieder Hallo sagen können.
Das gleicht das ständige Tschüss-
sagen wieder ein bisschen aus.
That's right.
- Maybe that's the strategy.
That we know
in a month it's always ... Yeah.
This very happy moment, again.
Ja.
- Ja.
Time to go?
- Time to go.
Bye, baby.
Tschüss.
Bis bald.
Sei ein guter Junge.
Gib ihm nicht zu viel Futter.
Tu ich gar nicht.
* Sie lacht. *
Das ist das dicke Fell.
You're okay, Leo.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
(Das war lange bevor der Flugverkehr
in ganz Europa
wegen des Coronavirus
zusammengebrochen ist.)
(Dass es für Florence und Niklas
bald viel schwieriger werden würde,
sich zu sehen,
ahnten sie da noch nicht.)
Bye.
Love you.
- Love you.
Hello.
Klar überlegt man sich das
und weiss: Es sind 1'600 km.
Willst du das so?
Willst du so eine Fernbeziehung?
Das ist ...
... schon bald mal
im Raum gestanden,
dass das einen Einfluss haben würde.
Zuallererst
dachte ich überhaupt nicht.
Du kennst mich.
- Yeah, that's why I'm laughing.
Nein, echt.
Ich reiste schon immer viel.
Von daher war das
von Anfang an kein Problem.
Ich dachte: "Na ja, gehe ich halt
hin und wieder in die Schweiz."
"Wo ist das Problem?"
Gut, die Konsequenzen ...
Was ich vergessen habe: dass ich
evtl. mit ihr zusammenleben will,
irgendwo.
Zusammen mit 253 Hunden.
Das habe ich vielleicht
ein bisschen vergessen.
Ansonsten ...
Ich habe es geschehen lassen.
Ich folgte meinem Herzen.
So lange
mit jemandem zusammen zu sein,
ist nicht schlecht.
Zehn Jahre verheiratet.
- Wir arbeiten zusammen.
Wir schlafen zusammen.
Wir frühstücken zusammen.
Das ist, wie wenn wir statt
zwölf Jahre 24 Jahre zusammen wären.
Man kann die Zeit
eigentlich verdoppeln.
Ja, das ist eine Challenge.
Ja.
* Meeresrauschen *
(Seit zwölf Jahren
sind Nicole und Rachid zusammen.)
(Die Romantik
überlassen sie inzwischen jenen,
die ihre Flitterwochen
bei ihnen verbringen.)
Wir legen unten Blumen
auf die Einzelbetten -
was natürlich keinen Sinn ergibt,
weil die sicher nicht im Einzelbett
schlafen, die Honeymooners.
Oben sollte auch alles dekoriert
sein. Wir schauen nach. Let's go.
Nice.
Two swans, kissing.
Yeah, it's nice.
- Do you like it?
Yeah, I like it very much.
- You're welcome.
Ich mag's nicht kitschig.
Simpel, mit einer Symbolik dahinter,
fertig.
Okay.
(Auf Sansibar ist bis auf die beiden
Regenzeiten im Frühling und Herbst
eigentlich immer Saison.)
(Deshalb können Nicole und Rachid
bis zu 40 Einheimischen
fast rund ums Jahr einen Job geben.)
(Kaum ein Tag vergeht, ohne dass neue
Gäste im Hotel Baladin einchecken.)
Hallo. Du bist die Lea, oder?
- Hi, ja genau.
Hallo. Freut mich.
- Freut mich.
Du bist die Nicole?
- Ich bin Nicole. Schön.
Gut, also ... Dann begrüssen
wir euch mit einem Welcome Drink.
Ihr dürft auswählen:
selbstgebrautes Bier aus Italien,
ein blondes, kühles, frisches.
Oder einen Saft. Was auch immer.
Einen Saft.
- Was Fruchtiges.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Wir haben uns sehr wohlgefühlt.
War toll, auch mit den Kindern.
Oh, danke schön. Vielen Dank.
(Nicole ist die Hoteldirektorin.)
(Sie hat auch einen Teil ihres
Ersparten ins Projekt investiert.)
(Mit Folgen, die sie und Rachid
nicht vorhergesehen haben.)
(Die lokalen Behörden wussten
nicht so recht, wie damit umgehen,
dass Nicole als Frau
das Geld bringt.)
(Als Investorin
war sie sofort willkommen.)
(Aber ihr Mann hat bis heute
keine dauerhafte
Aufenthaltsbewilligung bekommen.)
(Wäre er der Investor, hätte
seine Frau sofort eine bekommen.)
(Auch für die Beziehung
war das nicht immer einfach.)
Darf ich dich stören?
- Pas de probleme.
Wie sieht es jetzt mit
deiner Aufenthaltsbewilligung aus?
Die Situation ist, dass ich
nun schon seit zwei Jahren warte.
Deux ans?
- Ouais.
Aber Nicole
hat die Bewilligung bereits?
Ja, weil sie Investorin
und Miteigentümerin des Hotels ist.
Deshalb ging es bei ihr schneller.
Wie ist der aktuelle Stand?
Hat sich jetzt etwas geändert?
Die Arbeitsbewilligung habe ich.
Es sieht aus, als bekäme ich
nun die Aufenthaltsbewilligung -
vielleicht schon heute.
- Sicher?
Ja, vielleicht.
Hoffentlich heute.
Ich will keine Zahlen nennen.
Die Chancen stehen bei ...
... 55 %.
Et ca, c'est pas vraiment ...
Voila.
Wow.
Mega schön.
Ich empfehle euch,
das Fenster offen zu lassen.
Es ist mit Moskitonetz bespannt.
Hinten könnt ihr
an der Kordel ziehen,
da ist ein Rollo, zum Abdunkeln
und damit niemand reingucken kann.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt, kommt zu mir.
Ihr seht mich da frühmorgens,
spätabends.
Ja.
- Okay, sehr gern.
* Entspannte Klänge *
(Dass Nicole die Chefin
und damit Rachids Vorgesetzte ist,
hat sich auch
auf ihre Beziehung ausgewirkt.)
(Die neue Rollenverteilung
und seine Abhängigkeit von Nicole
waren für den ehem. marokkanischen
Polizeiinspektor nicht einfach.)
(Auch darum nimmt er heute
einen neuen Anlauf,
um seinen Status zu verbessern.)
You looked to the other side
before you crossed.
We can go, we can go.
Wow.
* Rachid seufzt. *
Hallo, Mr Eric.
Wie geht's? Gut?
Ist Mr Ali hier?
- Yeah, Mr Ali's here.
Können wir rein?
Guten Abend, Mr Ali.
Wie geht's?
Sorry about yesterday.
I could tell from your voice
you were a little nervous.
(Herr Ali hat endlich geschafft,
was Rachid seit zwei Jahren
Kampf mit den Behörden
erfolglos probiert hat:
Die Bewilligung ist bereit.)
But ... Did you call somebody today
or did you send somebody?
(Der Drucker sei kaputt gewesen,
deshalb habe es länger gedauert,
sagt Herr Ali.)
(Und übergibt Rachid
das langersehnte Dokument.)
... printing, then they gave me.
Can I have a look
at my residence permit?
And this is ...
... valid for two years?
For two years, until '22.
- Okay.
Thank you very much, Mr Ali.
Schön.
Dann können wir jetzt feiern.
Vielen Dank.
Besuchen Sie uns mit Ihrer Familie.
Kommen Sie zum Mittagessen
oder Abendessen.
Thank you.
Danke vielmals.
Bye, bye. Thank you very much.
- See you soon.
(Wieso jetzt plötzlich
alles so gut geklappt hat,
werden wir
wahrscheinlich nie erfahren.)
(Ein Schelm, wer Böses dabei denkt.)
Right. Let's go.
No.
* Rachid lacht. *
Sorry, let's go now.
- Run, run.
* Entspannte tropische Klänge *
Salut. And?
Nothing.
Non ...
Dis-moi. Non.
Vraiment?
Cool.
Felicitations. Wow.
- Merci.
Wow, wow, wow. Cool.
* Sie seufzt erleichtert. *
A toi. A nous.
A nous. A la residence.
Vive la Tanzanie.
* Applaus *
Thank you.
- Merci.
Wow.
# Take my hand.
* Herzschlag *
Ganz am Anfang,
v.a. als ich ihn kennengelernt hatte
und sagte, er komme in die Schweiz,
sagten viele: "Bist du wahnsinnig?"
Ich wohnte damals noch
bei meinen Eltern, bis wir auszogen.
Sie sagten: "Ja, aber ...
Du hast ihn drei Tage gesehen."
"Jetzt kommt der
einfach in eure Wohnung."
Da dachten schon einige,
dass das
eh nur so ein Ferienflirt sei.
(Es war
definitiv mehr als ein Ferienflirt.)
Ja, wir wohnen schön.
- Ja, und jetzt haut ihr ab.
(Cahil Parks und Martina Stutz
haben geheiratet
und er hat einen Job gefunden
bei den Pilatus Werken in Stans.)
(Und fast noch wichtiger:
Cahil hat sich bestens
bei Martinas Familie eingelebt.)
(Auch die Zwillingsschwester,
Melanie, und ihr Freund, Sandro,
haben ihn
schnell ins Herz geschlossen.)
So, let's try
our perfect self-made sticks.
Thank you.
Jetzt hältst du die voll ins Feuer?
- Kannst schon recht nahe ran.
Oh, mein Stock brennt.
(Die Idylle auf dem Buochserhorn wäre
perfekt, wenn Martina und Melanie
einander nicht bald
Tschüss sagen müssten.)
(Für die Zwillingsschwestern
nicht einfach.)
Das wird ungewohnt.
Aber ...
Solche Sachen werden wir
sicher trotzdem noch machen.
Halt entweder mit jemand anderem
oder einfach wir zwei.
Neue Freunde finden.
- Ja.
Wir freuen uns auch darauf,
sie zu besuchen.
Wir haben gestern
den Flug gebucht.
Es ist gut zu wissen,
wann wir sie wiedersehen.
Das macht den Abschied einfacher.
- Ja, das macht es einfacher.
Wenn man etwas in Aussicht hat.
Neun Monate.
Neun Monate sind es.
- Dann sehen wir uns wieder.
(Zum zweiten Mal innert zwei Jahren
müssen Cahil und Martina abwägen:
Wer geht Kompromisse ein?)
(Und was sind sie bereit,
für ihre Liebe zurückzulassen?)
Irgendwie gebe ich auf, was für mich
das Allerwichtigste ist im Leben:
Familie und Freunde.
Wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste,
dann wäre das schwierig.
Freunde und Familie sind natürlich
auch für mich das Wichtigste.
Aber mein Glück aufzugeben mit
meinen Hobbys und meinem Lifestyle -
okay, es war zwar
nur für zwei Jahre.
Still, you gave it up.
- Of course.
Wenn du gesagt hättest: "Komm
in die Schweiz und bleib für immer",
ich weiss nicht,
was ich gesagt hätte.
* Herzschlag *
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
(Einige Monate vor der Abreise
haben Cahil und Martina
die eigene Wohnung gekündigt
und sind bei ihren Eltern in Buochs
untergekommen.)
(Und man merkt schnell:
Auch wenn sich die ganze Familie
für das Glück der beiden freut,
leicht wird
der Abschied niemandem fallen.)
* Leise Gespräche, Lachen *
* Herzschläge *
Sie hat etwas vor sich,
alles neu, immer wieder neu.
Ich glaube,
dass es für sie einfacher ist.
Es ist aber trotzdem
genau gleich schwierig.
V.a. in dem Moment, in dem sie geht.
Der Abschied am Flughafen,
der wird sicher nicht einfach.
Und ...
(Melanie) Oh, nein, Papi.
Bei uns sind die Emotionalen
v.a. die Männer.
Die sind bei mir gelagert.
Du kannst eine Pause machen.
- Nein.
Als ich ihnen in die Augen geschaut
habe, habe ich gesagt: "Das ist es."
Das kann gar nicht schiefgehen.
Deshalb stehen wir
komplett dahinter.
Och.
Oh.
- Ist so.
So süss.
Komm, gib mir einen hug.
(Das war im Januar.)
(Da hätte niemand gedacht,
dass in den nächsten Monaten
alles ein bisschen anders würde
als geplant.)
* Herzschlag *
Mit sieben, acht Hunden
entspreche ich
nicht unbedingt der Norm.
Wenn jemand sagen würde,
er möchte gerne mit mir
zusammen sein und alles,
aber von sieben
müsse ich fünf weggeben,
dann müsste ich sagen:
"Sorry, nein. Das mache ich nicht."
Das klingt etwas hart, ich weiss.
Aber das sind für mich Lebewesen,
sie gehören auch zur Familie.
Das würde ...
Keine Liebe der Welt könnte
für mich diesen Verlust auffangen.
* Vogelkrächzen *
* Mehrere Hunde bellen. *
(Seit zwei Jahren
ist Niklas aus Schweden
die grosse Liebe von Florence.)
(Solange sie aber noch
im Kanton Solothurn wohnt,
gilt mind. genauso viel
Aufmerksamkeit ihren Hunden.)
(Insgesamt sieben Vierbeiner
besitzt sie.)
(Mann) Gut. Wir haben gesagt,
wir machen den Parcours.
Wir machen Fünfergruppen,
hier: drei, fünf.
Ihr könnt auf diese Seite.
Hopp, hopp, hopp.
- (Mann) Du kannst noch aufholen.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, Max. Komm.
Hast du Wurst,
um Max vorne durchzuziehen?
(Früher oder später,
wenn Florence ganz zu Niklas zieht,
wandern auch die Hunde
nach Schweden aus.)
Nein! Nein!
Die ist weg.
- Nein, noch nicht. Schau! Schau!
* Florence lacht. *
Ich bekomme keinen Kaffee.
* Lachen *
Es gibt auch Momente,
in denen man beinahe zweifelt.
In denen man denkt: Wie ist es an
dem Tag, an dem ich wirklich gehe?
Wie wird das sein?
Da macht man sich schon Gedanken.
Oder wenn etwas in Schweden ist,
bei dem ich mich frage,
ob ich damit klarkomme.
Aber das sind kurze Sequenzen,
die sehr schnell wieder ...
im Hinterkopf sind.
(Mit den Hunden haben die Zweifel
übrigens gar nichts zu tun -
im Gegenteil.)
Eigentlich wäre das der Grund dafür,
dass wir sehr gerne
nach Schweden möchten.
Wir haben
ein Grundstück im Wald gekauft.
Das wäre mit den Hunden ideal.
Der Grund, weshalb ich
noch hier bin, ist meine Tochter,
Noia.
Sie wurde im Oktober 17.
Sie ist noch in der Ausbildung.
Und ...
Sie ist ...
Sie hat ein psychisches Problem,
das es ihr erschwert,
im Alltag zurechtzukommen.
Deshalb möchte ich
noch da sein für sie.
(Es eilt sowieso nicht
mit dem Umzug.)
(Florence und ihre Tochter
haben noch Zeit füreinander.)
(Niklas hat
gerade erst damit begonnen,
auf dem Grundstück in Schweden
ein Haus zu bauen.)
(Bis das für Florence
und ihre Tiere bezugsbereit ist,
dürfte es noch eine Weile dauern.)
* Bellen und Knurren *
Max, Max, Max. Komm.
Ja, fein.
Fein, fein, fein. Warten.
Super.
* Sanfte Gitarren-
und Klavierklänge *
(Niklas Wibring wohnt in Jönköping
im Süden von Schweden.)
(Verheiratet war er zwar nie,
hat aber zwei erwachsene Kinder:
Linus und Enya.)
(Und eben:
seit Kurzem auch einen Hund.)
* Lachen *
Das ist ein Testhund.
Ich hatte noch nie einen Hund.
Dann traf ich diese Frau -
und die hat 200-300 von denen.
Und weil sie irgendwann
hierherziehen
und mind. 268 Hunde mitbringen wird,
will ich nun versuchen,
mich daran zu gewöhnen.
Das ist Leo, den ich zu Testzwecken
von ihr mitgenommen habe.
Den blinden Leo.
Er ist schon ein Jahr bei mir.
Wir haben es gut miteinander.
Solange er nicht in mein Bett kommt.
Ich habe nämlich
eine leichte Hundeallergie.
Wahnsinn, mit sieben,
acht Hunden zusammenzuleben
und allergisch zu sein.
Linus und Enya,
könnt ihr kurz zum Hund schauen?
(Diese Hundeallergie
hindert Niklas aber nicht daran,
fleissig an der gemeinsamen Zukunft
zu arbeiten - im Gegenteil.)
(Es zeigt höchstens,
wie ernst er es meint.)
(Sein ganzes Erspartes
hat er genommen,
um für sich und Florence
ein Traumhaus im Wald zu bauen.)
Natürlich, wenn sie
in einem halben Jahr sagen würde,
dass sie nun doch nicht komme,
wäre das schlimm.
Ich wäre -
wie soll ich sagen -
finanziell ruiniert.
Some of this.
(Seine Kinder hat Niklas übrigens
nicht gross miteinbezogen,
als er mit Florence Pläne
für ein neues Leben geschmiedet hat.)
(Auch von der Hochzeit
haben sie nur indirekt erfahren.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Herzschläge *
Etwas regt ihn furchtbar auf:
Lila und ich lieben ...
z.B. Schinken und Cervelat.
Das ist halt Schweinefleisch.
Und das findet er überhaupt nicht
cool, wenn ich das zulasse.
Sie ... Klar, als Kind,
das ist etwas, das ...
... schmeckt.
Und da gibt es
manchmal ziemlich Streit.
Quoi?
- Le jambon.
Ja, das mag ich gar nicht.
Das hat
mit gegenseitigem Respekt zu tun.
Es geht nicht um Religion,
sondern darum, dass ich
mitbestimmen will, was sie isst.
Aber sie liebt es so.
Das ist mir egal. Es geht
um Erziehung. Sie ist ein Kind.
Jetzt entscheiden wir noch,
was sie isst.
Ich mag diese Regeln nicht.
Bitte nicht mehr.
Wir brauchen Salami gar nicht erst
aufzutischen, wenn sie da ist.
Genau,
wir machen es nur noch versteckt.
* Meeresrauschen *
(Wenn es Abend wird im Hotel Baladin,
haben Nicole, Rachid und Lila
etwas Zeit füreinander.)
He, he, he,
non, on fait pas ca comme ca.
(Zu Abend essen sie meistens
im Restaurant des Hotels.)
Gnocchi.
Oder Cocoa-Ravioli?
Cocoa magst du, oder?
Mmh.
- Ja?
La, il y a des Ravioli.
Perfect.
Das ist einerseits super praktisch.
Andererseits
hat man keine Privatsphäre.
Jeder Gast sieht dich.
Es ist ...
Es ist kein Familienleben,
wie man es sich vorstellt.
Shukran.
Guten Appetit.
Warte, es ist heiss.
"Isch heiss" - what does that mean?
Qu'est-ce que ca veut dire, Lila?
C'est chaud?
Und?
Gopfriedstutz ...
Gopfriedstutz nomau.
Tu peux le dire?
So, fertig jetzt!
(Schweizerdeutsch) Fertig jetzt.
* Lachen *
(Nicole hat sich
ihren Traum vom Hotel erfüllt.)
(Rachids Traum war es,
mit Nicole eine Familie zu gründen.)
(Im Moment haben also beide das,
was sie sich immer gewünscht haben.)
* Sanfte sphärische Klänge *
(Und doch müssen beide
auch Kompromisse eingehen,
die ihnen nicht leichtfallen.)
Babou?
Babou, asante.
- Asante.
Don't forget.
- Asante, asante.
Assalam.
- Asante.
Jalla, komm.
Komm, let's go. Jalla, jalla, jalla.
(Nächste Woche bei "Hin und weg"
tauchen wir tiefer ein
in diese Geschichte auf Sansibar.)
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Wir hatten einen Deal:
Ich sagte, ich wolle das machen,
und er sagte, er wolle eine Familie.
(Und wir lernen ein Paar kennen,
das schon von der Grösse her
unterschiedlicher nicht sein könnte:
Claudia und ihr Basketballprofi Kub.)
Nicht Liebe auf den ersten Blick,
aber er hat mich sehr fasziniert.
(Und dann wären da noch Florence,
ihre Hunde und die Frage,
wie viel man
für die Liebe aufgeben will.)
Bin ich eine schlechte Mutter,
wenn ich trotzdem gehe?
("Hin und weg".)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020